how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and of course
the sp umc as well as spider-man 3
looks like it's going to be combining
multiple different universes into
one of course there's the big rumor and
reports of the spider-verse
electro coming into this universe as
well and who knows the sinister six
still could even pop
up and if that's the case it looks like
spider-man is going to be having a
pretty hard time during this film
and it does look like that is going to
be the case as today we have
a video of tom holland stunt double greg
townley has shared a video of himself
doing stunts and practicing
scenes for spider-man 3. and based off
of what he shared and what we see
it definitely looks like spider-man is
going to be having a lot harder time in
spider-man 3 than he's had before
and it also looks like they're going to
be kicking up the action a little bit
as well which of course is great news
because who doesn't love some good
spider-man action
so i'm gonna break down this new clip in
this video but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the spider-man news and so you
can enter this week's giveaway
for a chance to win an iron spider funko
pop just subscribe
like the video and comment down below to
enter so again this was posted by greg
townley tom holland stunt double for
spider-man 3. let's take a look and then
go over what is happening
so besides the fact that this is kind of
amazing that greg can do this stunt
flip through the air like that and then
still kind of land on his feet is truly
amazing but let's talk about what it
actually means for the movie
now some people may think that the stunt
double actually messed up but he didn't
he did
everything that he did on purpose and we
know this because if you listen
very carefully as he's flying through
the air doing flips you can hear
somebody say
yeah that's a good one
so the stunt is being done exactly how
it's supposed to be done
spider-man is supposed to hit something
and it's supposed to send him flying
through the air until eventually he
lands on the ground
somewhat on his feet but spider-man is
being chased
in this scene if you look closely right
as greg
leaves the platform to swing from the
rope slash web
you can see the other person on the
platform reaches for him he kind of
swipes out to grab him
he clearly misses but it's very obvious
that he's after spider-man in this scene
and another thing that is kind of
revealed here is that spider-man
probably just got roughed up a lot
spider-man is swinging to get away from
this person
but the fact that he kind of runs into
something here means that he's most
likely pretty worn out
and pretty beat up from this person that
he was fighting so what it looks like is
happening here is that spider-man gets
into a fight
and it's a little bit more than he can
handle because otherwise he wouldn't try
to swing away
so he gets a little roughed up and as
he's swinging away he manages to run
into something or an enemy hits him with
something
when we left peter parker at the end of
spider-man far from home his identity
was revealed and everybody knows that he
is spider-man now
but also everybody thinks that he killed
mysterio
and everybody came to love mysterio in
spider-man far from home which means
everybody probably hates spider-man
peter parker in this film
and just today we learned that
spider-man 3 is casting extras to play
protesters and news reporters and
although we are not 100
sure what these protesters are going to
be protesting we can probably assume
it's spider-man they probably won't
throw anything about real life into this
film so all the protests that have
happened in real life
aren't going to play a factor into this
these protests are most likely for
spider-man they want spider-man held
accountable for
killing mysterio even though he didn't
the public thinks he did
so it's not just going to be the
villains after spider-man in this film
the people are seemingly going to be
against him as well
so he's got a lot cut out for him in the
upcoming spider-man 3 film
and again judging by what we see in this
video he's going to be taking a lot of
beatings
it looks like he has a rough path ahead
of him but
that's why doctor strange is going to
come in and that's why we could possibly
get other spider-man
in this film as well to help out our
young peter parker
so let me know what you think about this
shared scene from tom holland stunt
double greg townley
who do you think spider-man is running
from in this scene be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on the latest
spider-man and mcu news
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof